ALEX FAABORG: All right,
good afternoon.
Thank you coming.
This is Advanced Design for
Engineers, and really glad to
have you here.
Design's often broken into two
components, form and function,
and this talk is no different.
We're going to have Christian
Robinson presenting on form,
and he designed the
Roboto typeface.
And I'm going to present
on function,
on interactive design.
And I got to work on Google Now,
which launched yesterday.
So as you can imagine,
I'm incredibly tired.
Being engineers, you guys know
how launching software isn't
making sure everything's
perfect in the end.
But while I am physically
incredibly tired, I am
extremely excited to be able
to give this talk.
The thing I love more than
actually doing interactive
design is teaching it, so it's
really exciting to get a room
of incredibly smart people and
to provide all of this
information to you So let's
dive into interactive.
Now this is a room of engineers,
I'm assuming?
Raise your hand if you're
an engineer.
Yep, OK.
So often engineers don't have a
tremendous amount of respect
for design, and it's
not that they don't
think design's important.
They realize it's critical
to the success of their
application, but the reason they
disrespect it is it's not
controllable in the way that
software is normally
controllable, and hardware,
because you're dealing with
people, and people can
be kind of random.
So because you can't control
the people, you feel like
well, I'll spend more attention
on the things that I
can control, the execution time,
the amount of storage
being used, if it's crashing or
not, if it's reproducible.
And it's not entirely true
that people aren't
controllable because really,
what we're fundamentally
dealing with is two
information processing machines.
And that's of course, the
CPU and the brain.
And in some ways, they're very
similar, they're both doing
computation, one parallel
processing, the other one
massively parallel.
One's base2, the other one's
based on action potential, so
you have dramatically more
computational power.
But where they start to be
different is we know exactly
how computers work.
We can go back and talk to a lot
of people that were kind
of instrumental in the field,
it hasn't been that long.
So computer scientists, there's
things they're still
discovering about how to make
things efficient, but it's not
like there's any part
of the machine we
don't understand yet.
Whereas if you talk to someone
doing neuroscience or
cognitive science, you say,
how does the brain work?
They have to kind of shrug and
say, we're still trying to
figure that out.
And that's OK.
We don't have to have a complete
knowledge of how the
brain works to still have
predictable results.
There's enough that we
understand about it that we
can rely on to get those
predictable results.
So for the purpose of this
talk, it's really kind of
dehumanizing where we're going
to treat people like
information processing
machines.
You might think, well no,
I'm a special snowflake.
And yes, you are.
But you're also, for the
purpose of this talk, a
uniform snow processing
machine.
So three aspects of
a great interface.
First, it needs to be
self-describing.
Secondly, you need to prevent
errors, and then third, make
users fast.
So we're going to dive
into each of these.
So starting out,
self-describing.
The first thing I want to talk
about is this notion of mental
model, and a mental model is
basically a simulation of
reality inside of your mind.
So to pose a question, how many
instances of this talk
are happening right now?
And of course, the
answer is one.
It's right there.
The photons are bouncing
off the screen at you.
And when you're in a big room,
you've got the talk there, and
that's reality.
But then on another side, you
have the fact that everyone is
interpreting the talk in a
simulation of the room inside
their own head.
So you have all these
simulations going on, and
these are the mental models
they're building of the
reality around them.
So this is very sort of
dystopian movie, maybe we're
all in our little pods
and we don't know it.
But what's important about this
is when you're dealing
with interface design, you're
not necessarily designing
reality as much as you're
designing the simulation.
You're designing how people are
going to think about your
application, and how they're
going to interpret it, and if
they're going to understand
things.
So looking at this just in terms
of a quick diagram, you
have the implementation, which
of course you're incredibly
familiar with, then you have
the interface, which is how
that implementation
manifests itself.
What's really important is the
mental model, the simulation
of the interface inside
the user's head.
This is something Alan Cooper
writes a lot about in his
early work.
And of course, you have
this fourth component,
which is the manual.
And often, the manual likes to
take the blame in email lists
or talking engineers, it's not
uncommon to run into, read the
fracking manual as kind of the
explanation of why this
doesn't work.
And just passing the blame
forward if you don't want to
blame the manual, you can always
blame the users, which
maybe they're stupid, maybe
they didn't get it,
that's why it failed.
And I would argue that it's
really not about the
intelligence of the user.
So to quickly make that
argument, let's say we take
four geniuses, we'll just select
Einstein, Turing, Eric
Schmidt, and you.
And we're going to run a lot of
experiments, so we're going
to need clones.
So we start cloning all these
guys and we put them in our
deep underground lair, and now,
clones are really expensive.
So we're going to have to keep
them safe, so we're going to
put them in a room like this.
And the rooms are to protect
them, because clones are
expensive, but it's also to
protect them from any external
information.
We want to have total control
over this experiment, right?
So every day, we bring
them into a testing
chamber, looks like this.
We start to teach them,
we start to teach
them about the world.
We go over various things like
traffic lights, common things
people are going to encounter,
turtles, you
get the general idea.
And then once we've got that
baseline knowledge of what we
expect them to have encountered
in the world,
we're not going over any
theoretical physics or
anything, just baseline
knowledge, then we start
running our experiments, and
here's where it gets fun.
So we show them a screenshot
and we say, looking at this
thing you've never seen before,
what does that button
do, and can they get it?
Can they get it right, even
though they don't have access
to anything other than what
they're seeing right here?
And they're starting to think,
well, the curvature is very
similar to the arc of the thing
that's next to it, it's
visually lighter so it feels
like it's sort of not there
like the other thing is there.
There's only one of these,
and it's just the side.
So they might not know for sure,
but they might start to
guess, I bet it creates
another one.
Just the way that it's shaped,
the way that it's placed,
conveys those types of things.
Or another example,
this one harder.
You say, OK, what does
HTTPS stand for?
And there's no way they're
going to get this right
because we didn't tell
them, right?
It's jargon.
It's an acronym they're
not going to get.
But it's green, we did teach
them about traffic lights, and
next to a lock, a metaphor.
So even if they don't get it
totally right, its sort of
placement and the various things
that it conveys, they
might get close enough to say,
well, it probably means that
this is better somehow.
So they're able to bootstrap
conceptually just up enough.
Or another example, this
one more visual.
We bring them in and we say,
what does this application do?
And they're going to say,
it's very pretty.
And then they're going to say,
I don't know, because while
this icon is pretty, also
I think, did you
work on this one?
MALE SPEAKER: No.
ALEX FAABORG: All right.
For the designer in the room who
worked on this, I'm sorry.
It's a great icon, but it does
not convey to the user in this
test chamber with access to no
other knowledge, what it
actually does.
It is a great application,
though.
It's shipped on all the devices
you guys have, you
should check it out.
I use it everyday.
This is Currents.
So what does this app do?
They're not going to know.
So I would argue that success
in these situations, it
doesn't have to do with their
intelligence, it has to do
with access to information.
Is that information embodied
in the thing
that they're using?
So quickly you're thinking,
all right, well, what if I
don't have this underground
testing facility?
That sounds really expensive.
And that's true, and this is
controversial, it's especially
controversial for any user
researchers in the room, or
user researchers
watching later.
But I would argue while it's
really, really useful to have
access to user researchers, you
don't absolutely have to
rely on them.
You could just start running
user tests in your own head,
basically short-term amnesia.
What you have to do is you have
to kind of encapsulate
your mind, you have to start
thinking, forgetting the
things that you know about your
interface, try to look at
it with fresh eyes, try to
think, OK, I've never seen
this thing before, which is hard
because you have seen it
before, really, really hard.
But if you can do that, if you
can look at it with fresh eyes
and try to have all the
assumptions fall away that
you've already built up, then
you're able to do that kind of
user test just on yourself
quickly right then.
And if you're just regularly
doing that, it's going to
really improve your
applications.
I think this is one of the most
important things that I
can convey.
But obviously, you're going to
be more familiar with the
underlying implementation
because you are literally
building it.
In the case of a clock, you
are probably intimately
familiar with each of the
gears and how they fit
together and all of these
details, but you have to just
let that fade away.
You have to think about,
OK, just the interface.
Is the interface conveying
the right things?
And then beyond the interface,
the mental model.
How is the user simulating
this in their head?
What information are they
getting out of it?
So back to the diagram,
letting that
implementation fade away.
So that's self-describing.
At least, that's talking about
if something should be
self-describing, but how
do you pull that off?
It's one thing to say it's
important, it's another thing
to tell you literally
how to do it.
So there's at least five ways.
The first one is consistency,
and this
is cheating, basically.
It works great, but it's also a
kind of a tautology to say,
hey, if I design something
that's things that the user
already knows, they're going
to know how to use it.
That is true.
You do not have to rely on
this entirely, though.
In fact, Google products are
often very different from
what's already in the
marketplace, and they still
are able to bootstrap knowledge
from users and have
them figure it out.
I mean, in the case of Gmail,
it was sort of a radical
reimagination of how email
interfaces worked, but it
still worked.
And also, if everyone did
consistency all the time, we
wouldn't see dramatic innovation
in interfaces.
So we're not going to focus
on this one too much.
Basically, it's really useful,
and you can guarantee that
users are going to understand
your application if you focus
on consistency, but it's
not the only way.
So the second one
is affordances.
Let's go back to the test
chamber, and let's say one
day, they encounter this, and
they've never seen it before,
and they're thinking, whoa,
that's really interesting.
This might actually be a way
out of the test chamber.
And how are they going
to figure that out?
Everything about this design
is designed to
convey what it does.
The way that the door is
recessed from the frame, the
curvature of the handle, the way
that you can just imagine
the handle rocking in.
You might not know on which side
of the door it's going to
open, and you might not know
what the words mean, but the
picture sure looks like yourself
and it seems to be
going through it.
But that's sort of cheating.
Just the physical design of this
has been very carefully
crafted so that when you look
at it, you understand what
it's going to do.
You understand that you
need to push on it.
And this is a type of thing that
we do just throughout the
day, constantly, where you
encounter stuff and you have
to look down and say, I'm
going to push on that.
It's just this kind of thing
that cognitively, you're just
constantly doing without really
even thinking about it.
And that's called an affordance,
and that's not
just in the real world, but also
in the physical world.
All these various widgets have
these physical properties that
are baked into their
visual design.
When you look at one of these,
you can very quickly infer how
you are going to interact
with it because of those
properties.
The way that the circle's
slightly larger makes it seem
grabbable, the way that it's
brighter on one side implies
that it's been sort of filled so
it feels like a track that
you can grab this thing
and move it on.
Seeing a check box, a square
in the presence of one that
has a check box, is going to
convey that that one could
also have a check box.
On and off, literally writing it
on the switch is going more
towards the direction of writing
your manual on top of
it, but the visual design
conveys what it does, the same
with the button.
So these are all affordances.
Basically, an affordance is
implied physics from the
visual appearance.
Moving on to the third
one, natural mapping.
So let's run a quick experiment
on the audience.
Say we're looking at a stove.
So the second dial, which
burner does it control?
And silence, you don't know,
because there's no way to
figure it out.
We could literally write the
glyphs on top of it, that
would help.
But the thing is, writing your
manual directly on the product
is cheating.
Then what if it wears off?
That's definitely one way of
doing it, but it's not a
natural mapping.
A better UI, and this is
something that Alan Cooper
likes to talk about, is if the
dials were in that same
configuration as four things,
then it just naturally affords
which burner they control.
This is also always true
of light switches.
So light switches only are
frustrating when they don't
actually map in order to the
lights in the room, and if
they do map in order, you
usually just flip the right
one without even thinking
about it.
If they don't, then you start
randomly hitting them to try
to figure it out and
getting frustrated.
So this is a natural mapping.
Another example, controls
in a car.
I love this one, because it's
actually two natural mappings
at the same time.
The first is it's directly below
the window, so it's a
sort of natural orientation to
where the window is, and also
the four controls map to the
four windows in the car.
Sometimes, these are placed on
the center console, which is
really weird.
So that's in the
physical world.
In terms of the virtual world,
we have things like this where
the Full Screen control has a
natural mapping to the window
becoming larger.
It's placed on the edge.
It seems to afford expanding.
In this case, the Account
Selector has a mapping to the
window, because the account
controls the window as a
whole, not an individual tab.
So that's natural mapping.
Basically, natural mapping is
correctly abstracted layout.
But even better than natural
mapping is direct
manipulation.
So especially in touch
interfaces, you don't want to
have abstraction if
you don't need it.
You don't necessarily need
little Close buttons on things
because you're able to literally
directly touch the
interface, whereas in the world
of mice and keyboards,
you had to have this type
of abstraction.
So for instance, closing an open
application on Android,
you're just swiping it away,
just as you would get rid of
something in the real world,
and that's a consistent
affordance throughout
platform.
So going back to the stove
example, what would direct
manipulation of a stove
corner look like?
This is, of course, kind of
curious because now the dial
is the burner and it's going to
light on fire, but you can
imagine maybe some kind of
gesture, or like, you create
fire, or you put it out.
It would be at least very
exciting, and you'd never be
confused over which dial,
because you'd have direct
gestural control over
the burner.
So that's the fourth one,
direct manipulation, no
abstraction, you actually act
on the objects themselves.
Then the fifth one
is metaphor.
So metaphor shows up a lot
in application icons.
Basically, what you're trying
to do is you're trying to
bootstrap off of something the
user's seen, either in the
real world or in the sort of
introductory phase of our
crazy experiment.
So things like telephones,
maps, various real world
objects, helps kind of frame
them and ground them in
something in reality
to explain what
the application does.
And you don't have to go
too far with this.
It's enough to just kind of give
them the cue as opposed
to having stitching or something
in your application,
unless you want to do
that because you
think it looks nice.
You don't have to be super
literal, but at least draw
that kind of distinction of,
this is the object that I'm
conveying to you.
And it's not just application
icons, but also it's sometimes
more fundamental things, like
we're just used to having a
light source which is above us,
the sun just shining in
the sky all the time, and the
way that conveys light.
So when you see a button, that
light source is conveying to
you that this thing is convex
and you can make it concave.
It looks like you
can push it in.
So it's just that kind of quick,
interactive affordance
that you're getting through your
experience with the real
world through that metaphor.
And also not just small widgets
but larger ones.
You know, a tab.
If you have that sort of same
curvature and angle, people
are going to be immediately
thinking of physical folders
they've seen in the
real world.
So major structural components
are going to be part of your
interface as well.
So metaphor is basically
abstract consistency.
So those are the five parts
about making it
self-describing.
So let's move onto the
next one, which
is preventing errors.
So the first one I want to talk
about is mode errors.
Obviously, engineering audience,
so how many people
think vi is better than Emacs?
Actually not that
many, all right.
Emacs versus vi?
Better?
So vi has a tremendous number of
mode errors because you are
in either insertion mode
or command mode.
And I say it has the mode
errors, because you could
blame the user.
I mean, it is their job to
maintain state in their head
of what's going on.
But maybe they got an email
or something, things are
distracting them, they're
thinking about their day.
Next thing you know, they're
entering commands when they
want to be entering text.
It's a classic example
of a mode error.
Another example, you're in
your car, put the car in
reverse, it checks on messages,
then floor it.
You don't have that mental state
of what mode the car was
it right then, or even just if
your garage door is up or
down, the occasional
mode error.
So to avoid these, you want
to make sure that your
application doesn't have modes
unless absolutely necessary.
And if you do have
a mode, there's a
couple ways to fix it.
If you have a mode where the
user is actually actively
doing something, it's
considerably more useful.
So like keyboard shortcuts, you
have that muscle memory of
sort of pushing the key in, as
you're in the Command mode,
once the keyboard shortcut
accelerator is invoked, so
you're not going to have mode
errors because you're actually
doing something.
If you have a very strong visual
change on the screen
during a mode--
imagine there was something
obvious to indicate this was
in Command mode--
that would help.
But generally speaking, you want
to try to avoid modes as
much as possible, because
otherwise you're going to have
mode errors.
Next one, reasonably
obvious, data loss.
It's often the user's fault, you
want to protect them from
themselves.
Google Docs does a really good
job with preventing data loss
where it's reasonably hard to
lose data with Google Docs.
You have to sort of type the
most important thing in the
world, pull the ethernet cable,
and knock the computer
off a cliff all in one gesture,
and it's hard.
Android phones, also really
useful, where all the data on
the phone is going to be backed
up into the cloud and
secured in your account, so
you're not going to lose all
of that really important
information.
So that's just some examples
of preventing data loss.
Also really important as people
move between devices is
to have access to information.
And those are major cases.
Also, you have to worry about
minor data loss, which is, you
did a change and you
want to undo it.
It is really important to
support undo across all the
various actions in your
application to help prevent
users from making
these mistakes.
So that covers preventing
errors.
Now finally, making
users fast.
Obviously, speed is something
Google cares deeply about, and
it's not just true of how things
operate, but also how
the user operates.
So the first thing
I want to talk
about is visual hierarchy.
Computer science obviously
focuses a lot on trees, the
various algorithms you can apply
on trees, and B trees,
and [? black ?] trees and binary
trees, and all these
various things, and breath for
a search versus depth for a
search, and actually, it
doesn't just apply to
computation.
Like obviously, if you're
caching data, you want data
that users access the most to be
higher in the hierarchy, so
you have the least number of
hops to get to it, a very
common thing with computing.
But also in terms of the
interface, in terms of the
visual search that people
are going to do.
So Gmail's actually a really
good example of this.
Let's look at your average Gmail
inbox where the first
thing, right off the bat, the
first branch point is read
versus unread.
Now in this case, all the unread
messages are grouped
together, but even if they were
kind of scattered, you
can easily visually select on
how dark it is, and just
immediately at a glance, just
kind of parsing it, you
immediately know which ones are
read versus unread, versus
some little tiny glyph that
was indicating it.
So that's the first branch
point, which is a good one,
because it's one of the branch
points that people often want
to branch on, knowing if they're
looking for something
new that they thought might have
come in versus something
they know hasn't come in.
The next branch point in the
visual hierarchy is author
versus message, and this is
achieved not through contrast
but through spacing.
So because you have a lot of
space here, it's really easy
to look at the Author field
versus the Message field, have
another branch point there.
Then the final branch point is
the subject versus the body of
the message, and here this is
less obvious because it's less
important, because we want
to build that hierarchy.
But you can also quickly
differentiate the subject line
versus the body, because
of that visual
difference in the hierarchy.
So here it's just spacing and
contrast are being used to
literally create this tree in
terms of the order in which
you're going to be able to scan
stuff and how easy you're
going to be able
to scan things.
So if you know you're looking
for an unread message from a
particular person, you have two
hops, and you can get to
it really fast.
So that applies to the
messages coming in.
Also in terms of the
interface itself,
you have visual hierarchy.
It's reasonably obvious looking
at this what the most
common control is, but just
dropping the color and the
contrast a little bit, let's
overlay some user metrics.
I should note, these are
entirely fictional.
I just made them up, but you can
imagine user metrics look
something like this.
Where you see more common
controls, like Compose, being
interacted with a lot, and
also their placement
reflecting that.
Then least common things, like
More Labels, rarely being
interacted with.
And this type of user metric,
you can almost sort of see it
when it's not there, in terms of
the spacing and the order,
and the visual dominance
of various controls.
On mobile as well, you want
to have in primary UI, the
controls that people are
interacting with a lot, then
in secondary UI, the controls
that they might occasionally
interact with.
So you can just pretty quickly
look at the user metrics and
create the visual hierarchy,
but it's not just that.
Also, from the visual hierarchy
you create, you can
actually kind of create the user
metrics, because people
are going to use stuff
more if they find it.
So it's really kind of circular,
where you're both
designing it and influencing
them in their usage, and then
their usage is influencing you
as a designer in terms of how
you want to expose stuff.
So it's not purely like you
could just have an algorithm
that's just going to feed the
data in and stuff gets bigger,
because you can actually
influence the data itself.
So diving into a couple other
things, Fitt's law.
Basically, this is solving
for time, given
target size and distance.
It's pretty straightforward.
You have your target time, you
have your distance, device
speed is like mouse speed, or
if it's a touch interface,
literally the speed of
the person's arm.
Device lag is if there's any
number of milliseconds to
actually process the event.
Based off of this, you can find
out that larger things
that are closer, you can
click on faster,
which is pretty obvious.
Hick's law is more
interesting.
It's about solving for time
based off of the number of
choices and probability.
It's been proven that if you
simplify the UI, people are
going to be able to click
on things faster.
So the argument of, why don't
we just introduce
a button for that?
It's because it has cost.
It literally makes interface
less efficient if people have
to search against it.
So equation here, you have the
number of equally probable
choices, which first of all, no
interface is going to have
equal probabilities,
so this form's bad.
What you actually want is
summation with the probability
of each one individually.
And based off of that, you can
determine when you have
something lined up with others,
what the access time
is going to be as people try to
locate the one that they're
looking for and choose.
So the combination of things
like Fitt's law and Hick's law
goes into the field of
cognitive modeling.
And basically what this is, is
predicting a performance
assuming highly trained users.
So unlike the self-describing
section, here you're assuming
that people know what
everything is.
And it's purely about access
time and how quickly they can
target the control
and get to it.
So a lot of this work
is actually done.
At NASA Ames, there's a really
good group doing it right next
to the Google campus, and
they're primarily doing it for
fighter pilots, actually.
This is a simulator of the F35,
and in this case, you
obviously have really highly
trained users because they
know what every control does,
and it's purely about visual
access time and small controls
and proximity
to other small controls.
But even for a standard
interface, a mobile
application or a desktop
application, you could do this
type of modeling to try to make
sure things are super
efficient, looking
at the metrics.
So that's how to build
great interfaces.
But the things we talked
about, self-describing,
basically the user building
a mental model and sort of
simulating in their head how
stuff works, preventing
errors, making users fast, the
idea of cognitive modeling.
That's how to make something
really easy to use.
Show an example.
This is really easy to use.
If you know you have to get to
the other side, we talked
about doors a bit, you know
how to get there.
You can assume the
thing rotates,
being inside a circle.
There's no mode errors, because
it only rotates in one
direction, and it's
easy to use.
It also looks like a human
cheese slicer.
It is not a happy door.
So that leads us to the second
part, which is visual design.
Here's Christian Robinson.
CHRISTIAN ROBINSON: So not to
contradict you, but I think
that the design of that is
actually really quite
appropriate.
It communicates perfectly, don't
even think about going
in me backwards.
I will hurt you and
mess you up.
So Alex started out talking
about users and how we can't
blame users because it's
not the stupid users.
I'm going to argue that users,
in fact, are very smart.
It's actually a hard problem to
design a system that people
can't figure out.
Even think about things like
cryptography, or DRM, or even
code obfuscation, where it's
difficult to create something
that people can't reverse
engineer.
So if this is also true of
UIs, then why are we here
talking about making
things easier?
The reality is that people just
don't care that much.
If they care enough, they
can figure things out.
But in reality, they have a lot
of things competing for
their attention, whether it's
all of the other apps in the
App store, all of the other
sites that are going on, all
the TV shows, they're watching
Game of Thrones, The
Bachelorette, both, and
comparing, I don't know.
So if something is really easy
to use and people don't care,
then it doesn't matter.
So my argument is, if we do
things to help people to care
more, move over to the right,
then even things that are very
difficult, like learning how
to drive a car, people are
going to do it.
Things that are really difficult
like riding a
unicycle, and I know that some
people care a lot about this,
but in my case, I haven't cared
enough to learn how to
use it yet, or something that's
both easy and care a
lot about, like eating a
sandwich, that's going to
happen all the time.
So the tricky part about this
is that a good portion of
these decisions that we make
as what we're going to care
about, what we don't care about,
actually happen a lot
below the conscious level, and
this plays out in the kind of
research that we do.
It's actually pretty hard to
find out what people care
about, and if you ask them
questions like, why do you
like that, or even, what do you
like, people are really
bad at giving answers.
You get kind of garbage data
back because we're not very
good at even introspecting
and knowing these things.
So as designers, our job is to
understand this and help
people to make choices.
Now, there's a lot that happens
in this process from
when something hits our
eyeballs for the small
percentage that it reaches
the top of our brains.
So you may have had this
experience in elementary
school where the teacher told
you that the eyes are not, in
fact, at the top of the head,
that the eyes are in the
center of the head, and there's
probably people in
your class that argued.
Or in my case, I remember being
the artist in the class,
thinking that my eyes had
betrayed me, or how could I
have not seen this?
It's so clear, once you
get the ruler out.
And as it works out, there's a
special unit of processing in
our brain for facial
recognition, and this is
speculation on my part, but
I think it's probably less
important, the information from
the eyebrows to the top
of the head, and so our brain
just kind of squishes it, and
what we think we're
seeing isn't
really what we're seeing.
This idea that design and these
ideas of perception
happen below consciousness
aren't new.
In fact, there are many people
that have made this made this
point that sometimes the best
design is invisible design.
A very famous essay
on typography--
famous for those of us who are
really into typography, so
famous for a small subset--
where Beatrice Warde makes the
case that good typography
should be like a
crystal goblet.
It's transparent, that
you can't see it.
You see the content inside, but
the glass is doing its job
best when it's almost
not there.
So a bunch of psychologists
at the
beginning of the last century--
I see a lot of people doing
this, recognizing a failure in
my position of the text there.
A bunch of scientists at the
beginning of the last century
wanted to figure this out.
They were a bunch of Germans,
they wanted to figure out how
to order things and group
things, and how we do that.
They call this idea of order,
they considered it order or
rightness, they called
it gestalt.
Here's an example of some
gestalt principles at work.
You can see here how some very
simple changes in the
structure of the data make
it so much easier to
process on the right.
Alex talked about these
hierarchies of information and
how, since we can't change the
algorithms in people's brains,
we have to speed things up
by structuring the data.
Well, these gestalt principles
are how we structure the data.
Now, I'm not going to
go through all of
the principles here.
I'd recommend that you read the
Wikipedia article on the
topic, it's great.
I could have just read
it and done well.
But I've distilled some of these
ideas into two practical
principles that you can put to
work immediately when you're
evaluating designs.
Here's the first one.
This is the thing that I wish
that people had told me on the
very first day of
design school.
It's line stuff up.
That's it.
Everything should be lined up
with something unless it has a
good reason not to.
So even if elements are at the
very opposite sides of the
screen and they're almost
aligned, line them up.
If we don't do it, then our
subconscious brains are
spending precious cycles trying
to figure out, why are
those things not lined up?
Does it mean something?
Does it not mean something?
It's almost like I'd compare
it to a memory leak in your
software, where something's
going on, you're not exactly
sure, but you're wasting
your resources.
Let's line that back up.
That's better.
So even stuff that isn't on
the same screen, let's say
three or four screens later,
you've got something that's
maybe in this case,
a little bit above
halfway down the page.
Line it up.
Even though it doesn't seem like
people will be able to
make that association, and
consciously they certainly
won't, our visual processing
systems are using that
information to know how
to decode this.
Now I might also point out, if
you do want to bring emphasis
to something, then not lining
it up is a really
great way to do it.
You can see in these suggested
paragraphs right here how just
pulling one line out of
alignment gives you a bunch of
information about what's
the most important
and a lot of structure.
Here's the second big idea.
Design the spaces.
Now, this is a little bit hard
to do because again, our
conscious brain is really good
at examining objects in the
foreground.
Backgrounds tend to be less
important once we've actually
picked out the objects.
But if we're designing the
experience, it's important for
us to help people do that, pick
out the groups in the
foreground.
One of the ways we do that is
by looking at the spaces in
between things.
Our subconscious brains are
constantly parsing our field
of view, looking at the spaces
between things, and when have
the same amount of space between
them, we very easily
and very quickly just rest.
We check that off.
Those things are grouped
together,
those things make sense.
In the case where every element
on the screen has
slightly different spacing,
again, our subconscious brains
are wasting cycles.
In our massively parallel
processing brain, there's
billions of threads that are
just in infinite loops trying
to figure out what's going on,
and in the best case, maybe
we'll still be able
to parse it.
In the worst case, we'll just
discount it as noise and we
won't understand the
intended structure.
So design the spaces.
Likewise, using bigger spaces
is a great way to
break things up.
We could talk about
white space.
So this is especially
true in typography.
This is kind of a typographer's
curse.
Once you see kerning, you kind
of can't unsee it and you'll
constantly be looking at, every
time you see a v and an
a, you're like, did
they kern that?
The idea is, just the squares
of the letters are drawn and
don't naturally fit together, so
you have to sometimes push
them together.
In the case of type designers,
spend many hours looking at
all of the possible
combinations and
straightening them out.
So the very last gestalt
principle says something like,
people can also order things
based on past experience,
which is a very short way of
kind of discounting the whole
rest of design.
It turns out that this is really
one of the biggest and
hardest parts.
All of style and culture and all
of these things fit in as
the very last principle.
If you look at this right here,
you can see some of
these spacing and grouping
principles, and help me to
understand, maybe make this
number easier to parse.
But if you've ever called
somebody in the US or looked
up something in an address book,
you know immediately
that this is a format
for a phone number.
It's not because of the spacing,
it's because of these
kind of learned ideas.
We have a lot of these, and
they're hard to deal with
because they're kind of vague.
The associations aren't super
crisp always, and here's an
example of that.
Let's consider for a moment
a grocer that wants to
communicate to everybody
that her produce
is extremely fresh.
And wanting to put her best foot
forward, she commissions
a sign, and she hires an
expensive designer, and they
may make it out of chrome and
neon, and she thinks, good,
now people will always
know that the
produce here is fresh.
Now contrast that with the
grocer across the street who
doesn't really think about it
too much, but all of her
produce that comes fresh from
the farm, just like the one
across the street, comes in
these cardboard boxes.
She cuts out pieces of the boxes
and just scrawls "Fresh
peaches" on it.
Now, which of these
two design systems
conveys, fresh peaches?
This is a good example of
the idea that better
isn't always better.
When you're communicating
something, these vague
associations that people have
been can be a very strong cue.
So as product designers, we
always have to be asking this
question, what associations are
people going to make from
what they're looking at here?
Sometimes it seems absurd
looking at a simple web form
thinking, what associations are
people going to make with
this thing?
What does this look like?
So in these design processes,
this is one exercise that we
do, and I would highly
recommend it.
It's not hard to get started.
Just pull up a whole bunch of
imagery and start sorting out
on the table, start making
these associations.
What should our product
feel like?
What does our product
feel like right now?
What do our competitors'
products feel like?
What associations do we
need to evoke in the
minds of our users?
So now we're talking about
how to make people care.
There's one last idea I want to
put out there, that one of
the best ways to make people
care about our products is to
show people that we care
about our products.
Now, this is a reality about
perception that's hard wired
into our brains that sometimes
very small things can make a
really big difference in
how we see something.
Now, I don't know whether, if
I download an app that has a
poorly-executed app icon,
whether it's going to be more
flaky or whether it's going
to crash on me.
I haven't necessarily seen the
data with that correlation.
But I do know that that's the
association that users are
going to make based on
millions of years of evolution.
When you see something that's
not quite the right color or
that has a hole in the wrong
place, you bite that fruit,
you might be seeing the
second half of a worm.
So also, we need to do not miss
the opportunities to do
the things that we
don't have to.
Those little pieces of design
in places where they're not
needed, where they're uncalled
for, tell the user that hey, a
designer was here.
Somebody thought about this.
They're like little love
notes for our users.
It's the interactive doodle on
the home page, or the mint on
the pillow, what you
put on the back of
the box in the package.
It's the hidden extra
level of the game.
There's value in doing these
things that don't have an
apparent commercial purpose,
where we're showing people
that we care so they'll care
enough to use our products.
In this case, PacMan didn't help
people to finish their
searches faster.
It probably actually
got in the way for
some people, me included.
But people loved it, and why?
Because we didn't
have to do it.
It's like a note or flowers.
It's these intangibles that
show people that we care.
Here's another small example
that comes from Google Now,
where the Context Header changes
based on your time of
day or your location.
And when we were making these,
during the process people
said, this is going
to be hard.
We're going to have to draw a
lot of things, we're going to
have to draw a lot of states.
That's kind of difficult.
And the answer was yes.
That's the point.
It's these little pieces and
these little touches that
don't necessarily have a
practical purpose that
demonstrate to people that hey,
if they thought that much
about this, then think about
how much work they put into
the actual search results.
Now, you have to be careful with
this because it's a very,
very strong message to send.
You have to make sure that
your product backs it up.
So how do we apply this to
thinking to products?
Well, it doesn't have to
be the large things.
The Pac-Man example, the effort
to actually make the
game was a lot smaller than to
produce the search results.
But simply ask yourself
this question.
What are the things that I can
do that I don't have to?
So that said, here's a couple
pieces of reading that we
recommend that you look into to
find out more about some of
these topics, like affordances
and natural mapping, an in Don
Norman's book, or the mental
models in Alan Cooper's
classic, About Face.
And for typography and layout,
one of my favorites is The
Elements of Typographic Style.
Tomorrow, there a number of
design sessions relating to
Android development, so take
advantage of those.
ALEX FAABORG: Let's move
onto questions.
[APPLAUSE]
And it was supposed to be on
the slide, but tomorrow at
5:30 PM at the W Hotel in the
living room, we're going to be
having drinks with the
Android Design Team.
So if you guys want
to stop by, that
should be a lot of fun.
And we're really eager to
take your questions.
We've got quite a bit of time.
So go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I don't actually have
a question, I just want
to say that was the best
presentation I've had since
I've been here, so
thank you guys.
ALEX FAABORG: You're welcome.
CHRISTIAN ROBINSON: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question about
lining stuff up.
So in Android, I would try to
put an image next to a text
view, and then there would be
this little bit of space from
the top of the text view until
the text actually shows up, so
it does not line up.
The top of the image does not
line up with my text, and it
bothers me.
I try to fix it, but there
doesn't seem to be
a way to fix it.
Should I even try?
CHRISTIAN ROBINSON: Yes.
Please try.
I am reminded again and again
that that's a little bit
difficult right now because the
reality is top of the text
as we perceive it is the top of
the caps, it's usually the
place where we want
to measure from.
And in this case in a lot of the
systems, it measures from
the clipping bounds.
So measuring from the very top
of the text, if you're
building these kinds of systems,
measuring from the
cap height and the baseline
is where you
want to measure from.
So you may have to
do some kind of--
people always hate negative
margins, or I don't know how
to technically achieve it.
AUDIENCE: I mean, I guess the
next question is, if I decided
to do it, how do I figure out,
what is the amount to shift
for my font?
Is there a computational
way to do it?
I don't want to just trial and
error, one pixel, two pixel, I
do it until it lines up.
CHRISTIAN ROBINSON: Yeah.
We can talk a little
bit after.
ALEX FAABORG: It's an important
limitation.
CHRISTIAN ROBINSON: Em height
times 0.23, I think.
ALEX FAABORG: But thank you
for trying to line it up.
That's great.
AUDIENCE: This is something I've
been really curious ever
since Google started rolling out
the new design, because in
Android, the basic theme is
always black, the background,
whereas iPhone is
always white.
So I'm wondering if you can
speak to that, or why you guys
decided that kind of design?
ALEX FAABORG: There's a
few functional things.
The OLED screens consume less
power when they're not
illuminating.
Also, they're occasionally very
bright, so you don't want
to just burn the retinas
of the user.
Those are very literal things.
Christian can speak to
the [INAUDIBLE].
CHRISTIAN ROBINSON: Particularly
when we first
launched Nexus 1, the OLED
screen on that device is
amazing, and some of these
design decisions were made
based on that.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So you talked a little bit
about how people have
assumptions that they've made
based on a world that we've
all got, and how that's not
always that important.
And like a good example of
that is that designers, I
think, try and do a lot with
color where green is a
positive action and
red is generally
error, warning, whatever.
And so in Gmail, the Compose
Mail button is a bright orange
red, and I've always wondered,
what is some of the thinking?
I don't know if you guys worked
on that, but what is
the thinking that makes you
break that really, really firm
color association model
that most of us have?
CHRISTIAN ROBINSON: So first
off, I won't put words in your
mouth, but when we're talking
about the design process,
sometimes it's really important
to get those
associations out of our mind to
make sure that we can work
on that more fundamental
level.
But those associations are
extremely important.
And so once we've kind of worked
out, how do we make it
work without these kind of
elements of style and trends
and all that stuff, it is really
important to layer that
stuff back on to evaluate
the work.
In terms of the specific choice
of that color, I can't
speak to it, except for
the fact that red is a
signal for, look here.
ALEX FAABORG: Also, I didn't
work on it either, so I don't
want to put words in the mouth
of the designers that did, but
one thing you can see from the
design is that the colors,
they have external consistency
meanings, but they also have
really good internal consistency
meanings, where
blue is always representing
Search, green is always
representing Share, and red
is representing Create.
And that's not the kind of
thing that you have to
actually know, or on a conscious
level know, but it's
the kind of thing that on a
subconscious level, as you're
trying to find the Search
button, or you want to quickly
share something, you start
to pick up those color
associations as you're
doing your targeting.
So I thought that was a
really nice touch they
did with the design.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I work at a fairly
large media company, and many
projects I end up working on
tend to have five or six
design cooks in the kitchen, and
I'm primarily an engineer.
I was wondering if you had any
suggestions on ways to
influence the design when I see
something bad or that I
disagree with from
that position?
ALEX FAABORG: So the first thing
is, you want to always
speak in terms of the user
base as a whole.
If you immediately go in and
say, I find this bad for my
usage, the designer is going
to be like, I don't care.
You are statistically
insignificant.
Even if what you're saying is
identical to the mainstream
views, it's just the phrasing.
So that's really key.
Also, if you can back up any of
the things you find wrong
with it with irrefutable
principles, then you're
actually having a debate on the
actual design, as opposed
to opinions.
We don't see opinion debates in
engineering as much because
you have these irrefutable
principles like, something
shouldn't crash, or it shouldn't
use too much memory,
or it should be fast.
So if you start grounding things
in mode errors, or
consistency, or the user being
able to find help if they need
it, things that everyone agrees
should be right, then
it's not really a debate as much
as you just pointing out
a bug that they need to fix.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I've worked on
projects with dedicated
designers, and then I've also
worked on projects that are
just a bunch of engineers
making something that
inevitably ends up
looking horrible.
Do you have any suggestions when
you have just engineers
working on a project, and any
things that they could do,
when they know they're making
something that's not
well-designed, what to do to
help improve the design?
ALEX FAABORG: Well, hiring an
agency is always an option.
People often discount that as
too expensive, or they haven't
done it before so they
haven't tried it, it
works really well.
And also, you often see a lot
of the return in having a
[INAUDIBLE] designed thing
if you're selling the
application.
If you're just doing it
yourself, trying to isolate
your mind and look at it from
the perspective of a user.
If you are able to, show it to
other people that haven't seen
it before, and do sort
of quick tests.
I Ask them to think out loud as
they're interacting with it
so you can hear their
thought process.
Sometimes everyone's so secret
about their stuff that you
can't do that.
So that's really important.
Do you have other suggestions?
CHRISTIAN ROBINSON: Another
thing for independent
developers that don't have a
very big staff is that for a
lot of these platforms, there
is a lot of work that's done
into making the platform and
making those pieces so that
they work and do the
right thing.
So looking at the platform
itself and kind of figuring
out the standard way that the
platform does things is a
really good way to get
oftentimes a good portion of
the way there.
ALEX FAABORG: Also reading
the style guide, I
should mention that.
Android has a great style
guide that we both
worked on, so biased.
But what's nice about it is it
doesn't just give you the
various principles, but it also
gives you kind of the
thinking behind all of them.
And it's not like a rule book
as much as guidelines so you
can understand, this is why
this will make your
application better as you
follow these various
guidelines.
CHRISTIAN ROBINSON: It's some
kind of another instance of
line stuff up.
Don't reinvent a new way to do a
list unless there's a really
good reason to.
Unless it really changes the
character of your thing and
there's a purpose, there's no
reason to invent a new kind of
scroll bar.
AUDIENCE: For the Android design
style guideline, I was
wondering what you guys foresee
in terms of how its
evolution is going to be over
time, especially with phone
devices, mobile devices.
The screen size is getting
larger, and a lot of times
I've heard that you want to
keep things closer to your
thumb, but with things like the
Action Bar Menu and the
Overflow Menu, it's so far away
on a large device that
you no longer have the
ability to easily
do single hand actions.
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah.
Well, on large devices you
have the radius of
thumbs on the edges.
You want to definitely
think about that.
And the style guide, it's
evolving as fast as the
ecosystem and the devices are.
We're constantly pushing out
updates, considering new
patterns, things like that.
So it's not like this sort of
fixed thing that everyone has
to adhere to as much as a kind
of organic living document as
we all collectively
learn more.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for the
phone number slide.
I really like that.
It reminded me of one of the
horrible failures of iTunes
that I've just been
annoyed by.
If you have a date, and you
format it with four numbers, a
dash, two numbers, a dash, and
two numbers more, that should
be in ISO format for
year, month, day,
and no other order.
If you're having sort of the
other random orders that some
locales like, then use the
slashes or whatever is sort of
standardized for that.
And it helps users so much.
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah and
especially thinking about your
users, because you're going to
have your own date format that
you're familiar with, but
knowing who you're designing
for is really important.
AUDIENCE: I do have a
question this time.
Can you talk about tools
a little bit?
I mean, Photoshop is the obvious
one, but what other
tools can you talk about?
ALEX FAABORG: So I really
like Fireworks.
It has more direct manipulation
of the objects,
you can actually do nine
slice symbols in it.
A lot of people use OmniGraffe
or Keynote.
For OmniGraffe and Fireworks,
we have stencils.
We also have a Photoshop stencil
for Android design.
Really, the granularity of your
mock-ups has a lot to do
with how final you want people
to think they are.
So if you show someone a
full-fidelity mock-up and ask
their opinions, they're going
to start commenting on the
colors and those types
of aspects.
If you show them a wire frame,
they're going to start
commenting on the organization
of the information, how you
flow through the application.
So it's important to create the
mock-up at the level of
fidelity of the feedback
that you want.
Otherwise, really just sketching
stuff on paper is a
very quick, fast way
of conveying ideas.
Early in the process, it's
about how many different
designs you can come up with
as opposed to creating a
perfect one, so that's also
important to consider.
AUDIENCE: A little bit taboo,
but a lot of us have apps that
are on multiple platforms,
like iOS as well.
I just wanted to see what
comments you might have on
like where I work,
there's like a--
to try to get it completely the
same on both, and there's
a lot of directions that
designers want to go to
consistency versus [INAUDIBLE]
for the platforms?
So I just kind of wanted
to see what your
comments are there.
CHRISTIAN ROBINSON: This is one
that comes up quite a bit
for designers in
this industry.
And the way that I think about
it is, from the product to
designer's point of view, what
we're dealing with is all of
these products across the
different platforms.
And so the first instinct is to
design everything exactly
the same because, and yes, it
works the same across all the
different platforms.
But from the user's point of
view, there are some users
that have three different
phone platforms in their
pocket at all times,
that's uncommon.
More often, users will have
one platform, and they're
using all of these different
parts of the platform.
And so when they're looking
for something to hang onto
from a consistency standpoint,
they're expecting things to
work like the platform.
So when you create an app that's
consistent for you but
not consistent for your user,
then it's maybe not making the
right choice.
So designing for the specific
platforms and designing for
those conventions, it's a
challenge to find a way to
express your brand across all
those platforms, but--
ALEX FAABORG: Also, your brand
should be stronger
than just the UI.
It's kind of silly if the
UI is your brand.
Your brand is about the
emotional connection people
have to your application, and
your colors, and watermark,
and things like that.
And then also, Christian
concluded his talk with
showing users that you care, and
also talking about how a
poorly-designed icon, does that
application crash more?
Your application, you could care
a lot about it, but if
it's identical to the other
platforms, it kind of looks
like it was quickly
ported over.
It doesn't convey that level
of effort, and people are
going to see that and make
judgments off of how much
effort you put into it.
It's kind of a negative
note to end it on.
All right, well thank
you for coming.